We have so much to cover today that I will
not waste any time as I normally do a lot
of time wasting.
Normally on this program, but not today.
So we have Trump events and Biden Harris events
to talk about.
We'll start with Trump.
Donald Trump yesterday very suddenly scheduling
a press briefing right at the time that Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris were having their
first joint event, which I will cover momentarily.
Donald Trump sounding very much the same yesterday
as in previous press briefings, not only repeating
some of the same things he said previously,
but even repeating the same stuff two, three,
even four times during yesterday's press briefing,
which was weird.
We were it it actually went so poorly that
Fox News even got away from it to instead
discuss the Biden Harris event, if you can
believe that.
But we will get to that.
And it does seem like Donald Trump was motivated
yesterday and this late scheduled event, at
least partially by trying to take attention
away from the Biden Harris event, which got
much more attention and much larger viewership.
It was bad from the start.
Donald Trump sounded particularly slowed down,
sort of that ambulant trump, sleepwalking,
sleep talking lowest energy that I've seen
from him.
Take a look here.
Good evening.
As we continue to confront the China virus,
we're rebuilding America's economy like nobody
thought possible, actually.
We're doing incredibly well.
Stock markets, it's up almost 300 points again
today.
Well, our economy is performing significantly
better than Europe, which people have to understand
very strongly.
It's performing better than any market anywhere
in the world, actually.
At the same time, Europe has experienced a
40 percent higher excess mortality than the
United States.
So that's what I call casual, xenophobic since
Ambulante Trump.
You'll notice that everything now is percentages
relative to the second quarter.
If you watch this program, I warned you about
this after historic declines and horrible
numbers in second quarter, we expected that
now we would start hearing about relative
to the second quarter.
This has grown so much that has grown so much.
I won't.
You're all now briefed on that because I've
been talking about it and warning you about
it for months.
So I don't think I need to spend too much
time on that.
Donald Trump still pushing this idea yesterday
that the election will be a fraud and even
mixing it here with Obama gate.
Obama gate, of course, is this greatest crime
in history that Trump has claimed Barack Obama
committed.
We never actually find out which laws were
broken.
What is the treason you claim is there?
But it doesn't matter.
It's all being wrapped up now.
The greatest fraud ever perpetrated.
Other than perhaps what they did to my campaign
where they spoke to my campaign, President
Obama, Biden and everybody else, and they
got caught.
Let's see what happens.
This will be one of the greatest frauds in
history.
So they're admitting that they want three
point five billion and they're not going to
do a deal that's good for the American people.
Sadly, this is working, and that's why I think
we need to keep talking about this.
Yes.
So fraud.
All right.
Whatever.
It's Trump again, but it actually has convinced
two thirds of Republicans, 65 percent, to
be more precise, that the election may not
be fair in November.
This is a strategy and we talked about it
yesterday.
Trump's fixated on it for a reason.
And it's because it's good for him to continue
harping on the election is not going to be
fair.
The election is going to be rigged.
The election is going to be a fraud.
Now, Trump eventually took questions and he
did take more questions than the previous
day when I think he took five mostly friendly
questions and then sort of skulked off the
stage.
Trump did take questions yesterday.
He got a good question about the corona virus
death toll.
Donald Trump keeps talking about how cases
don't tell us much because cases are merely
an artifact of testing and because we test
so much, as Trump says.
Cases don't really tell us how we compare
to other countries.
Reporter astutely says, well, but our death
toll is a nightmare.
In an in absolute terms and in per capita
terms.
And Trump just deflects and insists on talking
about cases instead.
What is this about?
If you had a about economics of Corbitt, deaths
in America are still going up, whereas in
Europe right now, zero deaths in UK, zero
deaths in France.
What's going up?
My cases.
If you look at cases and the cases are going
up because we do so much testing and we find
it and I call it fake media gold because we
do so much more testing than any other country.
And when you do all that testing, you find
cases going to save real force.
So later, I'm going to be covering the Biden
Harris event from yesterday.
And you will no doubt notice that the Biden
Harris event was on topic and coherent and
substantive, whereas with Donald Trump, it's
deflection and nonanswers and redirections.
And this actually at one point got really
interesting because Fox News reporter John
Roberts asked the key question about Trump's
idea for cutting the payroll tax, which he's
been floating recently.
You probably know if you watched my I guess
it was the Monday, Monday, Tuesday show that
the payroll tax funds Social Security.
So if you permanently cut the payroll tax
like Trump claims he wants to do, you immediately
have a funding issue for Social Security,
a funding issue that you create.
Nonetheless, Donald Trump, not shockingly,
when asked about this, is completely incoherent.
If you permanently rescind the payroll tax,
how do you pay for Social Security?
We're taking it out of the general fund.
And we'll get what we'll be doing is if we
do that, we'll get it approved.
In that case, by Congress and.
We'll take the money from other places other
than we will not take it from Social Security
in any way, shape or form.
How do you fund from the general fund where
the general fund just incurred a debt of 2.8
trillion?
All right.
But we're going to have tremendous growth.
We have tremendous growth.
You take a look at what's happening here next
year.
Unless somebody comes in who doesn't know
what they're doing and they start raising
taxes and forcing everybody to leave the country
or leave their jobs and companies to close.
We will have tremendous growth.
You will see growth like you haven't seen
in a long time.
This one he's actually been claiming since
being a candidate.
Any time Trump has a policy that makes no
sense from the standpoint of arithmetic.
Trump says it might seem like it removes money
and causes a financial shortfall, but it doesn't
because it's going to be so stimulative that
all of this new growth will show up and the
government is going to take in more money.
It's simply not happened.
I mean, the concept of it is the concept of
demand-side stimulus.
If you make the right moves from a financial
standpoint in the economy, you generate growth,
which creates new government revenue.
It didn't happen with Trump's tax cuts.
It certainly wouldn't happen when you cut
the pay.
Cutting the payroll tax, which funds Social
Security, will not generate growth such that
then you get even more money from Social Security
elsewhere.
This is a shadow campaign.
If it were to succeed to hurt Social Security,
despite claims that it's Biden who will hurt
Social Security, if Trump were able to permanently
cut the payroll tax, that would really damage
Social Security.
I talked about it in detail.
Again, it was Monday or Tuesday, so I won't
do the full analysis again.
Then we get into some so-called fun stuff.
If the term can really apply to horror show
press briefings, take a look at this feeling
that on November 4th, somebody is going to
announce schools are open, the country's open,
everything's open.
I really believe a lot of it's done for political
reasons.
We want to know the truth.
I think so.
But you're right.
Online is not the same as being in the classroom.
He really seems to think that the entire corona
virus response in the United States is about
him and him alone.
No one is going to say on November 4th.
If the news on November 4th is Biden defeated
Trump, no one is going to say open up all
the schools because it was safe all along.
The only way, November 4th, we'll see schools
opened is if on November 3rd cases go down
95 percent.
The idea that this is all about Trump is just
part of his narcissism, part of his delusions
of grandeur.
And it's a complete and total fantasy compared
with Ebola, where two people died in 2014,
the day of the midterms in November of 2014.
Ebola criticisms of Obama stopped.
You can even look at Trump's own tweets leading
even in October of 2014, Trump was hammering
Obama on Ebola, where two people died.
And after the midterms, you never heard about
it again.
Essentially, this was yesterday.
Maybe the most slowed down Trump that we've
ever seen.
Check out these pauses and of course, without
the even without the pauses.
What Trump is saying here would make no sense.
Well, when you sit at home in a basement looking
at a computer, your brain starts to wither
away.
We have a lot of good experience.
At that, just by taking a look at what's happening
in politics, studies estimate that school
closures last spring caused the average student
to fall 50 percent behind in math and roughly
35 percent.
I mean, just just disjointed, incoherent.
And then the wild and wacky Trump falling
apart refers to doctors as doctors, which
is something else altogether, of course, and
really continuing to struggle to speak.
The doctors also warned about the risk of
increased abuse.
Then Trump completely unable to say fatalities
multiple times.
He says fatalities.
And again, he has this look on his face where
it's almost like one part of his brain realizes
that.
The other part is saying something that doesn't
make sense.
It's like when he said we need to know the
oranges, the citrus fruit, the oranges of
the investigation.
He had a look like he knew there was a malfunction.
Couldn't get control of it.
Very, very similar here with fatalities.
It's ninety nine point nine nine five percent
of all fatalities are adults.
Think of that, ninety nine point nine five.
That is extremely close to 100 percent of
all fatalities.
Are adults children?
Look at that.
Yo yo Semin nights plasma fatalities just
over the last week.
Come on, guys, this isn't normal.
Something is wrong here.
And then the last thing before I talk about
how Fox News handled this briefing, Trump
quickly called on the right wing propaganda
network.
When the question was a complete non sequitur
about some and TFA Web site redirecting to
Joe Biden's Web site.
It was just a setup for Trump to link Biden
and an TIFA when there is no such link.
I'm not even going to play the question for
you.
I don't want to give away any airtime.
But right after O.J. and said, what about
this Antifa Web site that redirects to Joe
Biden's Web site, Fox News put up on a lower
third graphic.
Trump says Biden should denounce an TIFA.
And this is how propaganda is generated.
There is no anti for Biden story at all.
Oh, A.N. creates such a discussion by asking
a ridiculous question.
And next thing you know, Fox News has a quote
up on the screen about what Trump says.
Biden should do about antifa.
Last thing, this is really interesting.
Even Fox News had to cut away when Donald
Trump started ranting about Bill de Blasio
and dog whistles about violence in Chicago
and the like.
Fox cutaway and said, watch the rest on our
Web site if you want.
It's not even believable what's happening
in Chicago, where one weekend you had 78 people
shot and 18 die in a weekend and then successive
weekends.
You have so much of that happening.
And it's it's not even it's really not even
believable.
And if you let Democrats run this country
and we've stopped it from going other places,
if you let Democrats run this country, you'll
have all of your cities be just like this.
Thank you, Mr. President.
Good evening.
Welcome to Washington.
I'm Brad Bear.
President Trump holding his daily briefing.
There we have it streaming on Fox News dot
com.
You can see the rest of it.
He started by talking about the success of
the stock market in recent days, what he calls
a V shaped recovery from the virus shut down.
The president also promising that checks.
So Fox News saying no more for us.
And then very last thing I've said during
my live streams of these events that Donald
Trump repeats a lot of the same things he's
been repeating verbatim, the same talking
points on the virus since April or May.
It's almost like we haven't had months in
between and and one hundred and sixty thousand
deaths.
The recount put this together and it is actually
literally verbatim true that Trump is just
repeating the same stuff.
The United States has now conducted more than
70 million deaths, more than any other country
in the world.
India deal with America is just at risk.
Population one point five million residents
of nursing homes about five to about five
times that of other European countries.
Are on track to rapidly produce 100 hundred
million doses of vaccine.
A vaccine is in Beirut.
We've delivered over 1800 rapid point of care
testing devices to nursing homes.
So this is all very weird.
And we had a contrast yesterday of the alternative,
which was a Biden Harris event, their first
event together, which is what I want to talk
about next.